vous êtes la fille d'une actrice qui
s'appelle galina loguinova mais mal est
ailleurs mam elle vous a donné elle vous
est donné ce goût vous a donné ce goût
du en latin ça veut dire poulain oui
absolument vous a donné ce goût du
spectacle ouais en italien en italien
c'est la poule oui et puis c'est sa mère
votre père était pédiatre d'origine
yougoslave et il s'appelle monsieur je
vaux vite voilà milliards 1980 votre
famille quitte l'ukraine pour la
californie chaque en fait il m'a amené
au cours de tirs quand j'étais jeune
voilà et c'est pour ça il voulait
toujours un garçon il a pris cinq
c'est presque réussi en battant alors à
l'âge de 9 10 ans vous commencez à faire
des petites publicités des spots de pub
vous jouez dans un premier film et votre
carrière incroyable débute à l'âge de 11
ans mannequin avec richard avedon c'est
pareil à richard dunne c'est un des
meilleurs photographes du monde et vous
devenez super star de la photo très
rapidement en ce sens vous fait la une
du magazine mademoiselle et ça fait un
scandale énorme parce que quand les
éditeurs république sa personne n'avait
que 11 ans ça fait un scandale
oui effectivement en fait il jeter des
tomates pourries et les photographes
alors vous gagnez me l'a très rapidement
beaucoup d'argent à l'âge de 11 ans vous
gagnez déjà 3000 $ par jour à l'âge de
12 ans vous avez fait la couverture de
10 magazines et à l'âge de 15 ans vous
avez gagné votre premier million de
dollars sert qu'à l'époque où les gens
se demandent ce qu'ils vont faire dans
la vie milla se demandait avec qui elle
est signé un contrat voilà heureusement
votre mère veille sur vous et l'âge de
16 ans elle vous interdit de partir à
new york tout seul elle a eu raison
à l'âge de saison vous marier avec un
dénommé shawn andrews
on est maire fait annuler le mariage
heureusement qu'elle était l'ami là
c'est moi je voulais une carte de crédit
dans les détails mais je sais j'ai dit
je peux être adulte et j'étais là et je
me suis marié voilà voilà
alors votre maire à ce moment là vous
envoie à londres
pour oublier ce shawn andrews pour
travailler et pour travailler dans les
mains de l'émotion j'ai arrêté de
travailler comme un mannequin et je vais
jouer dans les petits cafés à londres et
partout en angleterre alors à l'époque
effectivement c'est votre période un peu
rebelle un peu underground à londres
vous appelez votre mère satan j'ai
toujours très sympa et non non je n'ai
jamais appelé ma mère saxo mais là donc
vous vivez à londres vous êtes un petit
peu rebelle ça vous fait de la musique
vous êtes obligé de rentrer en amérique
vous rentrez en amérique de toute
urgence parce que votre père a été
arrêté pour fraude à l'assurance il
céderait effectivement mon père a passé
huit ans en prison voilà monsieur oui
j'ai perdu mon père pendant huit ans
chercheur
à l'inversé
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu